Pewds: Okey, I'm alive *punch sound*
Pewds: FUUUUUUUUUUUCK!
*Happy moosic while everyone ingame dies*
*T h e r e  w i l l  b e  n o  s u r v i v o r s .*
Pewds: Ok, yea this is the best level
Pewds: Ok we gotta--we gotta duck when the sign comes
Pewds:do-don't do anything
Ken: I cant even see the sign
Pewds: It it wil come fo-
Ken: AHHHHHHHHH
Pewds: Yeah good job
Pewds: Ken's out. FINALLY DAT BITCH LEFT!!!
*laughter*
Jack: Check out my ass Pewds!
Pewds: Awwww yea look at my ass!
Pewds: Yeaaaaahhhh
Pewds: I can't see it tho--
Jack: SNIFF MY POOPY BUTT(Dafuq?!)
*SMACK!!*
Pewds: WAAHHHHHH
*UNDERTALE death music (goddamnit Assgore)*
Pewds: AHHH! SAVE ME! SAVE MEEEEEh!!
Pewds: HELP!
Pewds: NOO00O0OOO0O0OOOO
Pewds: I'm still going in the distance!
*Jack and ken screaming while pewds is laughing*
*HAAAX!*
Pewds: Oh my god!
Jack: WAT HAPPENED?
Yeah! (in sync) "We're holding hands "(nothing gay about that)
Pewds: NO no No N0
Ken: Yeah heh heh!
Pewds: Ken has to win, he has-- its a condition
*He-(SMACK!)*
(TO INFINITY AND BEYOND!!!)
Pewds: W0000AH!
Pewds: THE SIGN IS COMING THE SIGN IS COMING!
Jack: Ok we survive dis Ken
Pewds: YOU GOTTA JUMP(x5)
Pewds: OHHHHHH *SUCHWOW!*
Pewds: I broke ma back
Pewds: OW my eye!
Pewds: FUCK! GO Jack! GO JACK! I'LL BEAT DA SHIT OUTTA YOU!!!
Ken: AH! MY FOOT!
*more screaming and yelling*
Pewds: HE'S GOT MY HAIR!
Pewds: JACK FIGHTS LIKE A GURRRL (UH TRIGGERED)
Pewds: r u pissing on me?(no ? maybeh ( ͡° ͜ʖ ͡°))
Pewds: Really Ken? you cannot wait one fucking---  save me save me!
Jack: AHHH
Jack: NOOoooooo
Pewds: Oh great... Ken is a try harding as usual guys...
Leafy: Hey everyone, Leafy here™, I'm going to kill myself
*Triggered Leafy fans*
Jack: Felix don't die so fast this time
Pewds: ok
Everyone: AHHHHH
Pewds: HELP!
Pewds: There's a poltergeist!
Pewds: AHHH
Pewds: I'm coming guys! (that's what she said)
Pewds: I'm coming!
Pewds: OH MY GOD HE LOST HIS FA--- AHHHHHHHH
Pewds: Jeezus!
Pewds: Hey Ken, why dontcha-- why dontcha come over here where it's nice 'n wet?
*virtual orgy*
*sounds of pleasure and dying cats*
*Pewds came*
Pewds: I'm done
Ken: HEY! NO! NO!
Pewds: FUCK YOU!
Pewds: FUCK YOU! DATS RIGHT! IM DA WINNA! oh gawd
*action movie sounds*
Pewds: OH OH OHH HOW DID I DO THAT?
Pewds: HOW DID I DO DAT?
*Ken mumbling something*
Pewds: OOOOOOHHHHH YOU GOT KNOCKED DA FUCK OUT!
Pewds: NOOOW, we're gonna have a play in the
Papa Ken: WHAT DA FAQ YOU SAY TO ME?
Pewds: AHHH NO PLEZ PLEZ *pewds hops like a bunny*
Ken: where'd you go?
Ken: Jack, no!
Pewds: GET EM DOWN GET EM DOWN!
Pewds: I'll never let go Ken *titanic song- you know the one*
Pewds: I'll never let gooo(jack grabs poods)
Jack: Oh shit, oh shit- mistakes were made
Jack: NOOOOOOO00000OOOOO
*poods the bird*
*Pewds kills Ken*
Ken:AWW  YEEE*pewds laughs while he is assfucked by ken*
Ken: HAW HAW HAW YEA!
Pewds: No no no please
Ken: Ya like dat?
Pewds: How did you find me?
Jack: IM COMING FELIX!
*fighting and yelling* Pewds: Aw you knocked me out!
*i thought this game was GANG BEASTS not GANG BANGS*
*sounds of pleasure or a dying whale?*
Pewds: OHHHHHH!
Pewds: Jack's turn. OHHH!
Pewds: You guys like my Magikarp cosplay?
*Pokemon™ battle tune*
Ken: Splash attack!
Jack: AHH HA HA HA HA
Pewds: Ah-Yeeeaah!
Pewds: OOOO
Ken: Splash tackle super effective!
*what is this game anymore?*
Jack: The sound effects are so loud
Pewds: Ooh I like your uh hair doo you look greeeeaaaaat
ayy
Mark: Why dontcha cum wit daddy over here? ( ͡° ͜ʖ ͡°)  Jack: NOOO god almighty
Pewds: Let's get him all down, let's get Ken down
Pewds: Why are we all holding--- OW!
Pewds: NO STAHP!
Markiplier: Boys stop fighting, BOYS! c'mon boyz
Pewds: LET GO OF MY FUCKING EYE, DUUUDE!
*screaming*
Mark: *with a toaster mic* like this game
Pewds: NO! NO! NO........ JUMP ATTACK! Jack: Come here you-
Jack: smörgåstårta!
Pewds: *laughing* smörgåstårta!(pussy/cunt/sandwich)
Jack: Come here you fitta! (pussy in swedish)
Pewds: Eyyy, watch your fucking mouth *while jack swears in swedish in the background*
Pewds: HUG!
*aAAAAaah!*
Pewds: Awww yeah
*Pewds and frends humping the air*
Pewds: YEAAAAA MAN
Pewds: It's like a dog when it scratches it's ass
???
*intense music*
*You know what?*
*I don't need frands...*
*Hehahahahahahahahahahahahahahahahahahahahahahahahahahahahahhahahahahahahahhaaaaaaaa.*
*Poods smiles. His plan is almost regicide.*
*His mission is almost complete.*
Pewds: Awwwww, looks like you bois are in trouble!
*dramatic musica*
(Secretly Pewds singing)
(get rekt)
Ken: You were there the whole time?
Ken: u cant let go im scared!
Pewds: dad!
Pewds: Dad! Ken: Jack you're the super hero, listen to us
Pewds: Oh!  (I bed punched the jack?!)
Pewds: $ALADA$$
Pewds: WOAH! how the f--- oh nevermind :(
Alright! That was Gang (Bang) Beasts
Hope you Bros enjoyed. Check out Mark, Jack, and Ken if you haven't already for some reason
Link in the description
and as always *smooches fist*
STAY TOASTY, HI EVERYBODY, TOP OF THE MORNING!
Shitty comments by Jimmy Bielinski!
I dunno who made the real captions.
why are you still here
i mean there is nothing here
just go away